Speaker 1: All right. Let's talk about the Kanye
West video in which he says he likes Hitler,
he likes Nazis. Now, before I even get into this,
I want to say right up front, there are people
who are not in agreement with the things Kanye is
saying, but are dismissing this as merely being a
very public mental health episode. And that that's
the only thing the only commentary, the only
analysis that needs to be looked at. Ben SHAPIRO,
right wing commentator, is one of these people
where he says, Obviously, I don't agree with
this stuff. He's Jewish being Ben SHAPIRO, and he
doesn't agree that Hitler was good or whatever,
but that this is nothing. This isn't this has
nothing to do with politics, has nothing to do
with society or culture. It's just Kanye having.
Some kind of mental health episode. It is clear
from everything we have seen that there is a
mental health component to this, but it doesn't
matter in terms of the effect that this can have
on people who already sometimes dabble in these
sorts of beliefs, anti-Semitic beliefs, and who
need very little to be pushed to the next level
where those beliefs grow and grow and grow and
they can go, as we saw in the World War Two era,
from just ideas that crazy people say, come on,
that said, give me a break into much bigger and
terrible things. So let's not do the thing where
we go. Just a crazy person doesn't matter.
There's an entire movement. And by the way,
this Nic, one test guy who was on the Alex
Jones show alongside Kanye a couple of days ago.
Is are all of the things he says also simply a
mentally ill, you know, a mental illness episode?
Less clear. So let's just go right into it.
These clips are literally beyond belief,
except they're not. What I mean by that
is, if I simply told you six years ago,
hey, here's a thing that Kanye is going to say,
nobody would believe it. But then now, of course,
it's exactly the stuff that he is saying.
Kanye West, Nick Fuentes, after their dinner
with Trump appearing on the Alex Jones show.
Speaker 2: You're not a Nazi. You don't deserve
to be called that. A demonized. Well,
I. I see I see good things about Hitler
also. Oh, boy. Jew, I love everyone and Jewish
people that aren't going to tell me you can love,
you know, us and you can love what we're doing
to you, what the contracts are. You can love
what we're you know, what we're pushing
with the pornography. But this guy that
invented highways invented the very microphone
that I use as a musician. You can't say out loud
that this person ever did anything good.
And I'm done with that. I'm done with the
classifications. Every human being has something
of value that they brought to the table. Yep.
Speaker 1: And Kanye wants to fight for the value
of talking about the good things Hitler did. Now,
by the way, Kanye has no clue what he's talking
about. He says Hitler invented the microphone.
Most microphones in use today are thanks
to James West, who was a black inventor,
not because of Hitler inventing the microphone.
It's it's completely outrageous. Here's more
of this stuff, if you can believe it.
Speaker 2: I don't want to study. I think
Hitler was a really bad guy, and I repudiate
what Hitler did. I understand that the British
intelligence set him up. I like Hitler.
I don't like Hitler. And I know you're.
Speaker 1: There you go. And look at that. Look at
Nic. One test with this stupid grin on his face.
This is a big victory, folks. They've got
one of the most recognizable, well-known
black musical artists and celebrities generally
saying, I like Hitler. This is a major victory
for people like Nick Von Tests and the white
nationalist movement. They are absolutely loving.
Speaker 2: This cannot be shocking to that. I'm
not trying to be shocking. I like Hitler. I do
not I the holocaust is not what happened. Let's
look at the facts of that. And Hitler has a lot of
redeeming qualities. Well, see, this is why people
are able Nazi. So, I mean, I disagree with those
statements, but I get that I don't like the word
evil next to Nazis. I think we need to look at
the Nazis, some of the worst thugs that shut
people down. A lot of really bad things,
but they did good things, too. We've got
to stop dissonances all the time. Okay.
I know, I know. I had a supermodel. Yeah, I
could tell. The Jewish media has made us feel
like the Nazis and Hitler have never offered
anything of value to the world. Okay, well,
why would the Zionists be killing Jews in mass in
Israel with the boys and shot? Because they work
for Satan. They don't work for God. Exactly.
Speaker 1: Okay, so this stuff is completely
beyond the pale. I mean, it's it's beyond
any analysis. You can't analyze it for its
substance. And there's a moment which is sort
of surreal, where even Alex Jones tries to get
Kanye to walk back some of his statements
and Kanye just doubles down even further.
Speaker 2: I don't think Hitler was a good guy.
I get the the Hugo Boss uniforms. Amazing. But I
mean, just because you're in love with design,
you're a designer. Can we just kind of say,
like, you like it, you like the uniforms,
but that's about it. We know there's a lot
of things that I love about Hitler.
Speaker 1: And look at Nick Fuentes
grinning and nodding along or.
Speaker 2: A lot of things. Wow. Wow.
Speaker 1: Folks, this is what how how can we
say this is a meaningless lone nut? When there's
an entire movement behind the guy, there are
people who are behind these messages and they're
increasingly prominent. Nick Fuentes met with
Trump. He had dinner with Trump the other day.
And so it's really important that we not allow
this, as sometimes happens with anti-Semitism.
I've said it before. Some in the audience don't
like when I point this out. We shouldn't have a
different threshold for anti-Semitism than we do
for other isms or discriminatory statements and
claims and whatever the case may be. Okay, this
is dangerous stuff. And when we talk about it's
not about saying Kanye is the next Hitler.
That's not at all what the analysis is. But
it's important to remember that there were lots
of people in pre-World War two era Germany who
would say a lot of this rhetoric that's floating
around about Jews and all the different things.
It's just rhetoric. It's never going to go
anywhere. There's no it has no teeth. There's
no way it could ever go anywhere. And when people
assume that that's how more happens now, you don't
have to jump to the Holocaust. You can just go to,
well, more societal acceptance of. Public shaming
of Jews, for example. There's all these little
steps in between before we're at the Holocaust.
You don't have to go to that. One last thing here.
The there was just an interesting kind of moment
where a Kanye says that Trump actually loved
Nick Fuentes at the dinner that they went to.
Speaker 2: The future president you're talking
to right now. Is Nick, your running mate? Is that
old enough? Yeah. Yeah. Nick, how old are you? I'm
24. Maybe in a few cycles. And Trump love Nick. He
looked at me, said, Where did you find this kid?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Now, that's interesting because
that's exactly the type of language
Trump would use. Where did you find
this kid? Straight out of central casting, huh?
Speaker 2: No idea. Who was the guy that wrote
the speech that you didn't like? Jason Miller.
Jason Miller lied afterwards after he found out
who you were. And what did Jason say in the
press? To start off, because it started to
be like a series of lie after lie after lie
and fake. It wasn't a tweet of the truth,
social after truth, social after truth, social
faux. Give them the rundown on that. Yeah. So
initially we didn't publish anything about the
dinner. It was rumored that Jay went to dinner
with Trump. Then it was rumored that I was at
the dinner because I walked through the airport
in Miami. Then there was a statement from Jason
Miller, who spoke as a representative for Trump,
and he said while Nick Fuentes was not at the
dinner and it was only at that point which was
a lie. It was only at that point when we began to
respond. And he said he can't say that Nick was at
the dinner. That was a lie. But I mean, I actually
like the speeches of Jason Miller wrote maybe.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Alex Jones still
desperately trying to kind of keep some kind
of bridge to Trump there to some degree. This is
extraordinarily dangerous stuff. And sure, Kanye
West, probably mentally ill, seems pretty clear.
But we're not going to write off this entire
movement, which, by the way, has been around for,
what, thousands of years and say, no, it's not
meaningful. It's not important because Kanye is
mentally ill. We're not going to do it. And by
the way, you've got to see the reactions of some
to the stuff that happened over the last few days.